A lifeline for Ukraine's forces
severed this destroyed bridge
near back
mud on the last
main supply route to the front.
Bombed
a Ukrainian soldier
told CNN by a Russian missile,
meaning reinforcing troops
or getting people out immediately
becoming harder front.
We were on that road near Bermuda,
military vehicles, bombing
towards the fight
and coming back with a sign for victory.
Russian forces have made progress
at encircling the city,
leaving only the West open
to Ukrainian troops.
The ferocious fighting has left thousands
dead on both sides.
Wagner forces,
which have led the Russian charge,
have paid
a particularly high
price aberrations present to Ukraine
today.
Wagner's leader, Evgeny Prigozhin,
on the outskirts of Bermuda,
released a video claiming, quote,
The pincers are tightening.
He called on President Vladimir Zelensky
to withdraw his troops,
saying give them a chance
to leave the city.
Prigozhin regularly exaggerates
Wagner's gains.
Ukraine
blasted today's video
as part of a disinformation campaign,
but Ukrainian commanders admit
they are facing withering
Russian attacks.
The Eastern commander posted photos today
of a visit
to Bermuda
where he was briefed on the problems
with Ukrainian defenses.
Despite no announcement of a withdrawal,
some possible signs have appeared.
This background rail bridge
strategically bombed
by Ukrainian soldiers
to make it impassable.
Well, started launching.
The head of a Ukrainian
reconnaissance unit
saying they received
an order to immediately leave back mount
without given a reason.
In neighboring
Chad, if
you're soldiers from an artillery unit
told us they have no plans
to stop fighting here.
Fearing what could then happen
when in fact the measures are in Albany.
The problem is not just Russia
taking back Mount Hotham,
which says
they will not stop
and will keep destroying the next cities.
We need to wait
for reinforcements to come
and then kick them out.
Because of McAuliffe, winning is a big
So it is unclear
whether those reinforcements
are coming, Aaron.
But when speaking with those soldiers,
they did tell us that
they want to keep fighting back.
They think that if they lose back mood,
if Russia takes back mud,
then they will then Russia will use that
as a jumping off
point to keep pushing into Ukraine.
Take that next town
where we were in charge of air
and set their sights on other towns
and cities deeper into eastern Ukraine.
Aaron. Alex, thank you very much.
From eastern Ukraine, tonight.
And OUTFRONT now,
Dan writes,
He advises
Ukraine's armed forces
and was also just named president
of American University in Kiev.
He also just returned from Ukraine.
And Nina Khrushcheva
a professor of international affairs
at the New School
and the great granddaughter
of the former Soviet leader,
Nikita Khrushchev.
And so thanks very much to both of you.
I appreciate. It's good to see you both.
And Dan, obviously,
I know you're going to be spending
even more time there
taking on this new position
at the American University
in Kiev as well.
So when you sit back mute
and what's happening there, that bridge
being blown out.
But Alex was just reporting on
the provision saying surrender.
We're going to get you.
And it seems from
what we're hearing, right,
this hasn't been going the Ukrainians way
Mm mm.
And, you know,
I guess some
some experts are saying, look,
give it up in back loot,
lose the battle, win the war.
Absolutely.
It appears that the the feared Russian
offensive is in bad mood.
They're losing a lot of casualties.
They're losing over 20,000 a month dead
and about three times that wounded.
So since November,
they've lost about 75,000
killed in action.
So basically Putin
is betting everything on Obama,
which is not a strategic location.
So Ukraine is giving up some territory
which is not strategic.
It's a 70,000 city,
70,000 person city
that basically is not strategic
and has virtually nobody left in it.
And the entire Russian army
is being degraded
And by the
by by may or so,
they're going to be basically
a leaderless conscript army.
And that's when Ukraine can counterattack
and said, okay,
so you think that that
that's how they're playing this
or strategically doing this right now?
I mean, Nina, you know,
this is in the context of what Oleg
Deripaska said, that
they're going to run out of cash
by early next year.
You know, as we said, this is he did
call for an end of the war
in Ukraine at the beginning.
But this is somebody
Putin has known for a long time.
He's been very much in that inner
oligarch circle such that it is.
How significant is it that he is saying
it was a conference
in Siberia or something where he said
there will be no money next year?
It's not the first time he said that.
And at the beginning,
it was also a conference in Siberia.
And he also was very open that we need
the world.
We it will be over.
He promised that
Russian economy wouldn't survive,
but then it sort of somehow survived,
he said. Right. Right.
And he had
he himself said a couple of months ago
that apparently Russian market
economy turned out to be much better
than he thought it would be.
But once in a while,
he comes
out with this warning that
for now
he can get away with
because it is I mean, of course,
Russia will run out of money.
But I really don't think
that this is Putin concern anymore
because Putin is going to fight
until he can with the money or without.
And businesses
now are obliged
essentially
to pay for this war to a certain degree.
And so, you know, on this stand,
the top White House aide
today, John Kirby, told Abby Philip
that giving legal aid to
Russia is still on the table from China.
Right.
That's something
he Putin is obviously very much
trying to do. Right.
Because you talk about blackmail.
You talk about the reality in Russia.
He needs something.
He's running out of everything.
Running out of everything.
So what would would
would anything China could do
or would do
in the way that they would do it,
which wouldn't
be like a blatant in your face.
Here it is.
Would that change anything on the ground?
Well, Representative
McCaul has said that they fear
that there
that China
is going
to give 100 drones to Russia,
just starting to give arms to Russia.
Lethal arms would be very dangerous
and it would it be
an escalation of the war.
I think basically Xi
Jinping has seen a masterclass
in what not to do.
He's seen basically Putin
make every strategic blunder
to join him right now. It would be fatal.
On the one hand, he's
trying to negotiate peace.
On the other, he's threatening to
to give arms.
I think he's going to try to.
How do you
how do you
what's the right way to describe 100
drones, a drop in the bucket
or meaningful?
It wouldn't be significant,
but what it would be is symbolic.
That means they're actually going
in to support them.
So drones would be able to help the
Russian artillery fire
become more accurate.
And it is a big artillery war.
So, you know,
the Kremlin today said
strengthening the border
because of this,
what they call a terror
attack on a village along the border.
They said arm Ukrainians raided it
and Putin called the group neo-Nazis and
said this
you mean that I can elude you?
It is precisely these people who aimed
to deprive us of our historical memory.
Witness to deprive us of our history,
to deprive us of our traditions,
our language.
Nothing will work for them.
We will crush them
Now, of course, Putin then delayed a trip
he was actually going to make
to the region, the whole region,
claiming that this was the reason.
What do you read into
what's happening here?
Well, it was a terrorist attack.
I mean,
it was an attack
on the Russian territory.
And we know how Putin
takes this seriously
because it also not only I'm sure
a lot of people in the Kremlin
are being upset about that,
but also then becomes
the next cycle of propaganda,
because it basically validates
all the things about the Nazis
and all the things
that they wanted to destroy Russia
and so on and so forth.
And we're going to crush them.
And so you the Russians, don't be upset.
We are going to strengthen it.
We're going to make sure
that nothing is going to happen to you.
So basically, that rhetoric,
I mean, those acts
and then the rhetoric helps him
to push the war forward. Right.
But it's rhetoric.
It's well,
and it's also the way forward,
because every time when something happens
on the Russian territory,
then Ukraine is being bombed
twice or three times as much.
Right.
Well, of course, as we said, you know,
they took out that fighter jet today
and we're talking about tanks, 11 plane.
All right.
Well, thank you both very much.
And again,
Dan, we'll be heading back to Ukraine
in his new role
at American University Kiev.
So thanks so much. Thank you.